MARIE-JEANNE LEFEBVRE, locataire
évincée
- Ça c'était mon penthouse,
j'avais deux galeries, bien
organisé! Marie-Jeanne Lefebvre
a été forcée de quitter le 1150
il y a trois ans.
- L'immeuble, infesté d'insectes
et insalubre, devait subir
des travaux majeurs.
Une rénoviction comme on en
voit souvent. Un douloureux
souvenir pour la femme de 73
ans.
- Tu peux pas te l'enlever de
la tête. Un feu tu perds tout,
une inondation tu perds tout.
Ici, tu ne peux pas ramasser
rien. Ici on aurait pu ramasser,
mais ils nous ont pas donné
la chance.
- Une fois les travaux
complétés, elle aurait pu
réeménnager dans son logement,
qu'elle a visité.
- Il m'a montré mon logement en
haut. 1500, il dit : "Il est
beau, tout est fourni."
- Le montant du loyer avait
doublé. Elle payait 750 $ par
mois.
- 1500 $ pas chauffé, pas
éclairé, là, non.
PIERRETTE CLÉMENT, locataire
évincée
- Moi je payais 515 $, puis
c'est monté à 1500 $.
- Pierrette Clément a aussi fait
une croix sur le 1150
rue Marie-Anne Est où
les appartements, fraîchement
rénovés, sont désormais affichés
comme des appartements
de style condo.
- Oui, il y a de
la clientèle pour ça, mais
il faut quand même que
les autres puissent habiter
quelque part, là. C'est comme si
on était des déchets.
C'est comme si les gens qui sont
pas riches, on est
des déchets.
- Le mot "rénoviction" n'est pas
officiellement inscrit dans
la loi, mais de nombreux
organismes sonnent régulièrement
l'alarme : le phénomène prend
de l'ampleur à Montréal.
VÉRONIQUE LAFLAMME, Front
d'action, réaménagement urbain
- Ça participe à un sentiment
d'insécurité, ça participe à
la crise du logement qui est
vécue actuellement à Montréal et
il est urgent d'agir.
- Le propriétaire du 1150
Marie-Anne Est n'a pas donné
suite à notre demande
d'entrevue.
L'Association des propriétaires
du Québec rappelle que
les locataires ont des droits.
ANNIE LAPOINTE, Association
des propriétaires du Québec
- Le locataire a le droit
au maintien dans les lieux, donc
il a la possibilité de revenir,
sans nécessairement avoir
d'augmentation de loyer.
Ce qui fait peu de sens
effectivement pour
un propriétaire qui a beaucoup
de travaux à effectuer, qu'il
doit payer des milliers
et des milliers de dollars.
- Alors y a t-il une solution?
Pour ces intervenants du milieu,
c'est au gouvernement d'agir.
- Ça prend des dommages punitifs
exemplaires pour dissuader
les propriétaires récalcitrants.
Or, ce n'est pas le cas
actuellement.
- S'il y avait une modification
au niveau des critères
de fixation de loyer dans
un premier temps, ce serait très
bénéfique pour chacun.
Ça fait plusieurs années qu'on
tourne en rond à ce niveau-là,
qu'on fait des demandes.
J'espère que la situation va
ouvrir les yeux au gouvernement
cette fois-ci.
- La ministre de l'Habitation
Andrée Laforest se dit sensible
à la question.
Son cabinet affirme que
des travaux sont en cours
pour obliger les propriétaires
à justifier des travaux
d'agrandissement, de changement
d'affectation ou de subdivision.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, M